The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG: OK.
Just as we're getting
started, I thought
I'd add a few words
about a question that
came up after class.
Suppose, in that
discussion last time,
where you were given three--
you were given a
distance matrix--
you were given the
distance between x1 and x2,
between x2 and x3,
and between x1 and x3,
and you wanted to find
points that satisfied that.
Well, we're going to
fail on this example,
because if the distance here
is 1, the distance here is 1,
then by the triangle inequality,
the distance from x1 to x3
could not be more than 2.
And when we square it, it
could not be more than 4.
And here it's 6.
So what's going to happen?
What goes wrong in that case?
Yeah.
I hadn't commented on
that, and I'm not sure
that the paper that
I referenced does so.
So I had to do a little
search back in the literature,
because people couldn't
overlook this problem.
So this is the triangle
inequality fails.
And it's not going to help
to go into 10 dimensions,
because the triangle
inequalities doesn't change.
And it's still there
in 10 dimensions.
And we're still failing.
So what happens?
Well, what could happen?
Do you remember?
And you'll have to remind
me, the key equation.
You remember, we had an
equation connecting the--
so what is the matrix
D for this problem?
So D is-- this is
a 3 by 3 matrix
with these distances squared.
And it was convenient
to use distances
squared, because that's what
comes into the next steps.
So of course, the distance
from each x to itself is zero.
The distance from x
distance squared was that.
This one was that.
But this one is 6.
OK.
So that's the distance matrix.
And we would like to find--
the job was to find--
and I'm just going to write
down, we cannot find x1, x2,
and x3 to match those distances.
So what goes wrong?
Well, there's only one
thing that could go wrong.
When you connect this distance
matrix D to the matrix X
transpose X-- you remember
the position matrix--
maybe I called it G?
This is giving-- so Gij is
the dot product of xi with xj.
Make that into a j.
Thank you.
So Gij is the matrix
of dot product.
And the great thing was that we
can discover what that matrix--
that matrix G comes
directly from D--
comes directly from
D. And of course,
what do we know about this
matrix of cross products?
We know that is
positive semidefinite.
So what goes wrong?
Well, just in a word, when
we write out that equation
and discover what G is, if
the triangle inequality fails,
we learn that G doesn't
come out positive definite.
That's really all I want to say.
And I could push
through the example.
G will not come out
positive definite if D--
if that's D because it can't.
If it came out
positive definite,
then we could find an X.
So if we had the G, then
the final step, you
remember, is to find
an X. Well we know that if
G is positive semidefinite,
there are multiple
ways to find an X.
This is positive semidefinite
matrices is what you get out
of X transpose X's.
And we can find an x given a
G. We can find G given an x.
So it has to be that
this won't be true--
that the matrix G that
comes out of that equation
will turn out not to
be positive definite.
So it's really quite nice.
It's a beautiful little
bit of mathematics,
that if, and only if,
the triangle inequality
is satisfied by these numbers--
if and only if--
then the matrix
in the D matrix--
then the G matrix that
comes out of this equation--
which I haven't written--
is positive semidefinite.
If the triangle inequality is
OK, we can find the points.
If the triangle inequality
is violated-- like here--
then the matrix G is not
positive semidefinite,
has negative eigenvalues,
and we cannot find the point.
Yeah.
I could recall
the G matrix but--
the G equation, but it's coming
to you in the two page section
that does distance matrices.
OK.
That's just-- I should
have made a point.
It's nice to have
specific numbers.
And I could get the
specific numbers for G,
and we would see, no way.
It's not positive definite.
OK.
So that's just
tidying up last time.
I have another small
problem to talk about,
and then a big question of
whether deep learning actually
works.
I had an email from
an expert last night,
which changed my view of the
world about that question,
as you can imagine.
The change in my world was, I
had thought the answer was yes,
and I now think
the answer is no.
So that's like rather
a big issue for 18.065.
But we'll-- let's
see about that later.
OK.
Now Procrustes' problem.
So Procrustes-- and it's
included in the notes--
that name comes
from a Greek myth.
Are you guys into Greek myths?
So what was the
story of Procrustes?
Was it Procrustes who
adjusted the length of his--
so he had a special bed.
Procrustes' bed--
certain length.
And then, he had
visitors coming.
And instead of adjusting
the length of the bed
to fit the visitor,
Procrustes adjusted the length
of the visitor to fit the bed.
So either stretched the
visitor or chopped off
part of the visitor.
So anyway-- the Greeks
like this sort of thing.
OK.
So anyway, that's a
Greek myth for 18.065.
OK.
So the whole idea, the
Procrustes problem,
is to make something
fit something else.
So the two things are--
so suppose I'm just
in three dimensions
and I have two vectors here.
So I have a basis for a
two dimensional space.
And over here I have--
people-- space scientists
might have one computation
of the positions of satellites.
Then, of course, they
wouldn't be off by as much
as this figure shows.
But then they have
another computation
using different coordinates.
So it partly rotated
from this picture,
but also it's partly got
round off errors and error
in it between the two.
So the question is, what's the
best orthogonal transformation?
So this is a bunch of vectors,
x1, x2, to xn, let's say.
And I want to modify them
by an orthogonal matrix--
maybe I'd do it
on the other side.
I think I do.
Yeah.
Q, to be as close as possible
to this other set, y1,
y2 up to yn.
So let me just say it again.
I have two sets of vectors.
And I'm looking, and they're
different-- like those two
sets.
And I'm looking for the
orthogonality matrix
that, as well as possible,
takes this set into this one.
Of course, if this was
an orthogonal basis,
and this was an
orthogonal basis, then
we would be home free.
Q-- we could get equality.
We could take an
orthogonal basis directly
into an orthogonal basis
with a orthogonal matrix Q.
In other words, if x was
an orthogonal matrix,
and y was an
orthogonal matrix, we
would get the exact correct
Q. But that's not the case.
So we're looking for
the best possible.
So that's the problem there--
minimize over
orthogonal matrix--
matrices Q. And I just
want to get my notation
to be consistent here.
OK.
So I've-- I see that starting
with the y's and mapping them
to x's--
so let me ask the question.
What orthogonal matrix Q
multiplies the y's to come
as close as possible to the x's?
So over all
orthogonal Q's I want
to minimize YQ minus X
in the Frobenius norm.
And I might as well square it.
So Frobenius-- we're
into the Frobenius norm.
Remember the-- of a matrix?
This is a very convenient
norm in data science,
to measure the size of a matrix.
And we have several
possible formulas for it.
So let me call the matrix A.
And the Frobenius norm squared--
so what's one
expression, in terms
of the entries of the matrix--
the numbers Aij in the matrix?
The Frobenius norm just
treats it like a long vector.
So it's a11 squared,
plus a12 squared,
of all the way along the
first plus second row, just--
I'll say nn squared.
OK.
Sum of all the squares--
just treating it
like a long vector.
OK.
This-- but that's a awkward
expression to write down.
So what other ways
do we have to find
the Frobenius norm of a matrix?
Let's see.
I could look at this as A
transpose A. Is that right?
A transpose A. So what
what's happening there?
Remind me what-- yeah.
I would get all that.
I would get all these by taking
the matrix A transpose times
A. But what--
sorry.
I'm not-- I haven't--
I've lost my thread
of talk here.
So here's-- oh, and then I
take the trace, of course.
So that first row--
first column of A times
that one will give me the--
one set of squares.
And then, that one times
the other, and the next one,
will give me the next
set of squares, right?
So this is going to--
if I look at the trace--
so now, let me.
So I just want to look
at the diagonal here.
So it's the trace.
You remember, the
trace of a matrix--
of a matrix M is the sum
down the diagonal M11,
M22, down to Mnn.
It's the diagonal sum.
And-- everybody
with me here now?
So that term on the diagonal--
A transpose A--
gives me all of that.
Then-- or maybe I should
be doing AA transpose.
The point is, it doesn't matter.
Or the trace of AA transpose.
That would be-- those would
both give the correct Frobenius
norm squared.
So traces are going to come
into this little problem.
Now there's another formula
for the Frobenius norm--
even shorter--
well, certainly
shorter than this one--
involving a sum of squares.
And what's that one?
What's the other way
to get the same answer?
If I look at the SVD--
look at singular values.
I think that this is also
equal to the sum square of all
the singular values.
So it's three nice expressions
for the Frobenius norm.
The nice ones involve A
transpose A, or AA transpose.
And of course, that connects
to the singular values,
because what are-- what's the
connection between singular
values and those--
and these guys--
A transpose A, or AA transpose?
The singular values are the--
or the singular values
squared are the--
AUDIENCE: Eigenvalues.
GILBERT STRANG: Eigenvalues
of A transpose A.
And then when I
add up the trace,
I'm adding up the
eigenvalues and that's the--
that gives me the
Frobenius norm squared.
So this is a--
that tells us
something important,
which we can see in
different ways, that the--
so to solve this
problem, we're going
to need various facts, like
the QA in the Frobenius norm
is the same as A in
the Frobenius norm.
Why is that?
Why?
So here I'm multiplying
every column
by the matrix Q. What happens
to the length of the column
when I multiply it by q?
AUDIENCE: It doesn't change.
GILBERT STRANG: Doesn't change.
So I could add up the length
of the columns all squared.
Here I wrote it
in terms of rows.
But I could have reordered that,
and got it in terms of columns.
That's because the length of
Q times any vector squared
is the same as the
vector squared.
And these-- take these
to be the columns of A.
So for column by column,
the multiplication by Q
doesn't change the length.
And then when I add up
all the columns squared,
I get the Frobenius
norm squared.
And another way to say it--
let's make that connection
between this fact--
that Q didn't change
the Frobenius norm--
and this fact, that the
Frobenius norm is expressed
in terms of the sigmas.
So what does Q do to the sigmas?
I want to see in another
way the answer to why.
So if I have a matrix
A with singular values,
I multiply by Q--
what happens to the
singular values?
AUDIENCE: Don't change.
GILBERT STRANG: Don't change.
Don't change.
That's the key point
about singular values.
If I multiply-- so A has a
SVD, U sigma V transpose.
And QA will have the SVD
QU sigma V transpose.
So all I've changed
when I multiply by Q--
all I changed was
the first factor--
the first orthogonal
factor in the SVD.
I didn't change the sigmas.
They're still sitting there.
So-- and of course, I could
do also A on the other side--
different Q. Same Q or a
different Q on the other side
would show up here, and
would not change the sigmas,
and therefore would not
change the Frobenius norm.
So these are
important properties
of this Frobenius norm.
It's a-- it looks messy to
write down in that form,
but it's much nicer in these
forms and in that form.
OK.
So now, if I can just--
then we saw that
it involves traces.
So let me make a few
observations about traces.
So I'll just-- we want to
be able to play with traces,
and that's something
we really haven't done.
Here's a fact-- that the
trace of A transpose B
is equal to the trace
of B transpose A.
Of course, if B
is A, it's clear,
and it's equal to the
trace of BA transpose.
So even do little
changes in your matrix
without changing the trace.
Let's see why one
of these is true.
Why is that first
statement true?
How is that matrix
related to this matrix?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] transpose.
GILBERT STRANG: It's
just a transpose.
If I take the transpose of
that matrix, I get that.
So what happens to the trace?
I'm adding down the diagonal.
The transpose has no effect.
Clearly, this is just a fact
that the trace doesn't change--
is not changed when
you transpose a matrix,
because the diagonal
is not changed.
Now what about this guy?
I guess we're getting back
to old fashioned 18.065,
remembering facts
about linear algebra,
because this is a
pure linear algebra.
So what's this one about?
This says that I can reverse
the order of two matrices.
So I'm now looking at the
connection between those two.
And so let me just-- to
use different letters--
CD equals the trace of DC.
I can flip the order.
That's all I've done here is.
I've reversed B
with A transpose.
I reversed C with D.
So why is that true?
Why is that true?
Well, how shall we see
the truth of that fact?
So these are really
convenient facts,
that make a lot of people use
the trace more often than we
have in 18.065.
I'm not a big user of
arguments based on trace,
but these are identities that go
a long way with many problems.
So let's see why that's true.
Any time you think
about trace, you've
got two languages to use.
You can use the eigenvalues.
It's the sum of the eigenvalues.
Or you can use the
diagonal entries,
because it's the sum of
the diagonal entries.
Let's use eigenvalues.
How are the eigenvalues
of CD related
to the eigenvalues of DC?
They're the same.
If these matrices
are rectangular,
then there might be some
extra zero eigenvalues,
because they would
have different shapes.
But zeros are not going
to affect the trace.
So this is the same
nonzero eigenvalues.
OK.
And so on.
Yeah.
OK.
Let me just-- let me try
to tell you the steps
now to get the correct Q. And
let me tell you the answer
first.
And I'm realizing that all
important question four--
does deep learning
actually work?
We're going to run
out of time today,
because we only have
a few minutes left.
I suggest we bring
that question back up,
because it's pretty
important to a lot of people.
There's-- I had lunch with
Professor Edelman, and he said,
you know, deep learning and
neural nets have had a record
amount of publicity and hype
for sort of computational
algorithm.
And-- but I had--
I've had people now tell
me that typical first--
if you create a network--
using Alex's design,
for example--
the chances are that it
won't be successful--
that the successful networks
have been worked on,
and experimented with.
And a good structure has
emerged, but didn't--
wasn't there at the start.
So I think that's
a topic for Monday.
And I'm really just
realizing, from talking
to people in the field, that
it's by no means automatic.
That structure-- even if you
put in a whole bunch of layers--
it may not be what you want.
OK.
So I'm-- let me finish
this argument today.
Let me give you the answer.
So what's the good Q?
I have matrices Y and X. And
the idea is that I take it--
I look at Y transpose
X. So that'll
be all the dot products
of one set of vectors
or the other set of vectors.
That's a matrix.
And I do its SVD--
U sigma V transpose.
So multiply this.
Multiply Y-- the two
bases that you're given.
Of course, if Y
was the same as X--
if it was an orthogonal basis--
you'd have the
identity, no questions.
But generally, we have--
it has an SVD.
And we're looking for
a orthogonal matrix
of the best Q is--
Da dun da duh.
I mean, it's the right time
for expressions of amazement.
It is UV transpose.
OK.
So that gives us the answer.
We're given X and Y. We're
looking for the best Q.
And the answer comes in
the simplest possible way.
Compute Y transpose
X. Compute its SVD,
and use the orthogonal
matrices from the SVD.
Yeah.
And I'm out of time so proof--
it's [INAUDIBLE] line later--
either to just send
you the section online,
or to discuss it
in class Monday.
But I'm really planning Monday
to start with question 4.
And meanwhile to ask a
whole lot of people--
everybody I can find--
about that important
question, is--
does deep learning usually work?
How-- what can you do
to make sure it works,
or give yourself a better
chance to have it work?
So let's-- that's
up for Monday then.
Good.